[Music]
gentleman is unfortunate we were
planning on having the cast of
workaholics on the show tonight but due
to a last-second scheduling conflict
they had to cancel in the middle of
tonight's show
luckily they were able to find a
replacement group from another realm
whose latest album purple magic is
available now please welcome the Wizards
[Applause]
it's about to get real real magical up
in this [ __ ] I beat that potion mixing
spellcaster dragon riding wizardry put
hat with a six-foot beard it's only
getting bigger put staff up in my hand
it'll shrink you down to size all I need
is the tale of I knew there's some
platypus eyes I can't fail to make the
titties just bounce don't be wizards
give me my book give me my coal burning
something to cook I'm a crazy ice wizard
I ain't gonna die trust me on that
maybe you try just can't we gonna win
the best beginning everybody in the room
Spanish shop we don't magical fools -
wizards all up in me don't do what
[Music]
your winch's on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
on a blizzard
[Applause]
always
[Music]
[Applause]
way to determine our show